what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the latest events in
the seven deadly sins story including
what might be a clear set up for a
seventh of these sins sequel or spin-off
I'm sure that most of you have heard the
rumor by now multiple news outlets are
claiming that the seven deadly sins
manga will be ending its run in just
three to four chapters but as anyone who
reads the manga can tell you that is not
even close to enough chapters for a
satisfying ending however in Chapter
three for three we got what looks like a
clear set up for a possible seventh at
least since equal or spin-off featuring
the king of chaos Arthur but also
featuring the remaining members of the
seven deadly sins in a supporting role
so let's talk about all the latest
events in the story and the potential
sequel right now if you enjoyed the
seven deadly sins content on this
channel you want us to keep it go and
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
or you just haven't subscribed please
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications a big thank you to all of
our anime our patrons who make videos
like this one possible I will talk more
about patreon at the end of the video
but first please be aware that this
video will contain seven deadly sins
manga spoilers as I said we're talking
about the latest events in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the name of chapter 343 is
an everlasting Kingdom and this chapter
reveals a lot about Arthur and his
ultimate goal it also provides some
intriguing clues about where the story
could be going from here as the chapter
gets going the sins and Arthur are still
facing off against caf-pow Luke and
actually cath mocks Arthur for saying
that he has figured out a way to defeat
him as you'll recall back in the
previous chapter Arthur's seem to have
had a Eureka moment where he apparently
came up with a way to defeat Kath and
half jokingly in that video I said that
Arthur might be planning to have some
cat casserole basically I said that
instead of cath eating Arthur Arthur
could just eat cat
this would allow him to defeat the
monster and get the stolen fragment of
chaos
back inside of him at the same time and
it turns out that this is exactly what
Arthur actually had in mind as katha tax
yet again attempting to consume Arthur
and everyone else in sight
Arthur turns the tables on the monster
Arthur uses the power of chaos to turn
everything around them into a giant
mouth with endless fangs and as the
fangs descend upon cath cath tries his
best to resist Kath declares that as a
direct descendant of chaos he is the
only one fit to wield chaos power not
Arthur in the past we were told that all
the creatures from purgatory were
created by the mother of chaos so
technically that does make cath [ __ ]
a descendant of chaos since Cass is a
creature from purgatory but here's the
interesting thing
Hawke and his brother Wilde are also
creatures from purgatory so by that
logic Hawke himself is also a direct
descendant of chaos I wonder if this
will come into play at some point in the
future knowing what we know now about
the power of chaos Hawke might really
have the potential to become a lot
stronger than we could have imagined by
the end of the story Hawke strength may
become more than just a meme as caf-pow
Luke struggles to push back Arthur's
attack Arthur asks the Beast to tell him
what he hopes to accomplish with the
power of chaos if you were expecting
some deep philosophical answer sorry to
tell you that cath answers by saying
that he just wants to destroy everything
with a form he just wants to destroy
destroy destroy everything in the world
not a very compelling villain motivation
but I guess you have to respect the
insane narrow-minded focus that cath
seems to have as a villain cath doesn't
have a tragic past he doesn't have a
master plan he doesn't have a deep
philosophy he just wants to break stuff
Merlin says that calf appears to be a
cluster of destructive will wrought by
chaos and this brief statement by Merlin
made me think of something is it
possible that chaos power or the will of
chaos actually split itself into
different creatures of purgatory
so then cath
represents the destructive will of chaos
and other creatures of purgatory like
Hawk represent something else some other
aspect of chaos perhaps there is more to
the backstory of Hawk Hawks brother wild
and Hawks mama a backstory that is
directly connected to the power of chaos
and that is yet to be fully revealed
after giving his reply Kath fires back
at Arthur asking him what he wants to
use chaos power for did Arthur actually
learn his lesson about the inevitably
fleeting nature of all things or is he
going to keep trying to build another
Kingdom even though that Kingdom will
also be destined to eventually crumble
and fall like all kingdoms do
Arthur reveals that he isn't concerned
about being knowledged as a great leader
by others or being loved as a king his
goal is simply for everyone to live
happily the message that Arthur wants to
get across is this it doesn't matter
what others think of you but what you
think of others this is actually a
pretty profound piece of philosophy
right here so many of us spend way too
much time worrying about what others
think of us do other people like us do
they hate us do they talk behind our
backs and so on most of the time we have
no control over what other people think
of us and yet we allow ourselves to get
stressed out about these things anyway
but what's the point of being stressed
out and upset about something over which
you have no control no amount of
stressing out is going to change
anything so why bother concerning
yourself with the opinions of other
people the one thing that you can't
control is how you think of others are
you being too judgmental of other people
are you talking about other people
behind their back are you being rude
harsh or critical towards others for no
good reason this is the part that you
can control and figuring this out is the
key to happiness you shouldn't worry
about the things that you cannot control
don't worry about how other people act
or what they think of you that is up to
them not you what you can control is how
you act towards other people and how you
interact with them you can choose to be
a good person
and live a happy life by focusing on
those things that are within your
control and by ignoring those things
that are out of your control again I
really like this philosophy I love this
approach and I just wanted to talk about
it a bit here Arthur then declares that
he wants to establish a land where
nobody suffers and nobody grieves a safe
land where nobody will feel terrified of
anything he vows to create this
everlasting kingdom Kath mocks this idea
repeating yet again that nothing is
everlasting in this world nothing except
for chaos but in that moment Kath seems
to realize what Arthur is getting at and
meliodas Merlin seemed to realize it as
well chaos is indeed the only
everlasting thing in this world and
Arthur is the king of chaos in the next
moment Kath is sucked into the giant
mouth in the sky and absorbed into our
third the world suddenly returns to
normal and the sins an Elizabeth
realized that Kath is gone and the full
power of chaos has been returned to
Arthur Excalibur is stable once again
and under Arthur's complete control
meliodas and the sins decide to support
Arthur in his goal they tell him to go
for it to try and create the everlasting
Kingdom that he had talked about the
seven deadly sins vowed to stand with
Arthur and to support him and even if he
makes mistakes they will be right there
with him and this is how the chapter
ends but I have to say that this final
part in particular gave me very clear
sequel vibes first Arthur announces that
he has a very ambitious and borderline
impossible goal and then the sins
encourage him to pursue it and they
promise to be there to support him along
the way it is almost as if a brand new
journey is just beginning a journey
featuring Arthur as the main character
but still keeping the sins there in a
supporting role over the last few years
there has been a lot of talk about a
potential sequel or spin-off featuring
Arthur as the protagonist but most fans
of the seven deadly sins love the sins
themselves a lot more than Arthur so
many people were critical of this idea
however if
there is an Arthur sequel in which the
original sins still play a prominent
supporting role I bet most seven deadly
sins fans will still read it if the main
seven deadly sins series ends and the
Arthur sequel is the only place where we
can find meliodas bond Merlin and all
our favorites you better believe that I
will be reading it even though I
certainly don't think that Arthur is as
great a protagonist as say meliodas bond
or Eskin or it is important to remember
that the sound that lee sin's manga has
consistently been one of the top 10
selling manga in Japan and the franchise
including the manga anime and video
games has made a ton of money while it
is possible then the entire series could
really end for good if that happens in
the next few chapters there is no way
that we will get a satisfying ending at
the same time if there is some type of
continuation including a potential
sequel featuring Arthur then a lot more
money can still be made from this
franchise and that is why I think that a
continuation is definitely possible in
the manga industry like in pretty much
every other industry money talks and if
the seven deadly sins is extremely
profitable it wouldn't be surprising if
the creator and the publisher continued
to find new ways to profit from it the
end of chapter 3 4 3 definitely seemed
like the setup for a new adventure and a
potential story continuation to me and
at the very end after the sins said that
they would stand with Arthur Arthur
states that the sins are his everlasting
goal this might mean that Arthur simply
admires the sins and their friendship
but it could also mean that Arthur's
everlasting goal was to become one of
the seven deadly sins with esken organ
rest in peace Big Daddy sunshine there
is now an open spot for Arthur to become
the new 7th cent I know that compared to
esken or Arthur is nowhere near as epic
and there is no way that Arthur can ever
fill esken or shoes as a character but I
wonder whether Arthur could potentially
join the sins as an official member and
that can be the starting point for a
brand new continuation to the story
please let me know what you guys think
will Arthur become the new 7th sin and
will there be some sort of continuation
of the seven deadly sins story after
this main story finishes its run
and of course here on the channel I will
continue to follow the seven deadly sins
series and I will keep you posted on
whether the series really will end and
whether there will be a sequel or a
spin-off of any kind if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more please
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to animal parole or you just
haven't subscribed yet please subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you don't go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and selecting the option that says all
YouTube is gonna bury a lot of our
videos that's just the way it goes I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime out pro patrons for supporting
our work and making these videos
possible with all the constant problems
on YouTube patron support is more
important than ever thank you guys so
much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata alone Adam the world stealers the
school bus
Tyson Kadena a quite respect and part a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldred's fitted ala beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's key on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP of Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Eve Argus Sean tart Joe Stanton JCCC
waka very Gucci and Jessica Kayla Fong
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]